Je voudrais commencer en disant : "Houston, nous avons un problème."
Nous entrons dans une seconde génération sans progrès
en termes de vol spatial habité. En fait, nous avons même régressé.
On a une très grande chance de perdre notre capacité à inspirer notre jeunesse
pour explorer et continuer cette chose très importante
que, en tant qu'espèce, nous avons toujours faite.
C'est ainsi que, par instinct, nous sommes partis explorer,
nous nous sommes hissés vers des endroits difficiles, nous sommes allés dans des lieux toujours plus hostiles.
Nous nous sommes rendus compte plus tard, peut-être à notre surprise, que c'est grâce à cela que nous avons survécu.
Et je pense vraiment
que ça ne suffit pas d'avoir des générations de gamins
qui pensent qu'il suffit d'attendre avec impatience la nouvelle version
d'un téléphone portable avec une fonction vidéo intégrée.
Ils ont besoin d'aspirer à l'exploration, la colonisation
et aux percées technologiques. C'est de cela qu'ils ont besoin.
Nous devons les inspirer parce qu'ils ont besoin de nous conduire et
de nous aider à survivre dans le futur.
Ce qui m'inquiète particulièrement, c'est ce que la NASA est en train de faire avec cette nouvelle doctrine de George W. Bush
pour les quinze prochaines années -- oh, mince, j'ai foiré.
On reçoit des instructions très spécifiques de ne pas parler de politique.
(Rires)
Ce que nous attendons avec impatience, c'est --
(Applaudissements)
Ce que nous attendons avec impatience,
ce n'est pas seulement de l'inspiration pour nos enfants.
Les plans actuels ne permettent même pas vraiment
aux gens les plus créatifs de ce pays -- les ingénieurs dans le spatial
chez Boeing et Lockheed Martin -- de prendre des risques et de tenter des choses nouvelles.
Nous retournons sur la Lune, 50 ans plus tard,
et nous y retournons en planifiant tout, explicitement afin de ne rien apprendre de neuf.
Ca m'inquiète vraiment. Mais de toute manière,
ce que je veux partager avec vous aujourd'hui,
c'est de la façon d'inspirer les gens
qui seront nos grands leaders de demain.
Ce sera le thème de mes 15 prochaines minutes ici.
Et je pense que l'inspiration commence quand vous êtes très jeune :
enfant de 3 à 12 voire 14 ans.
Ce qu'ils observent sont les choses les plus importantes.
Jettons un oeil sur l'aviation.
Il y a eu une magnifique courte période de quatre ans
pendant laquelle des choses formidables se sont passées.
Ca a comencé en 1908, quand les frères Wright ont volé à Paris et que tout le monde s'est dit :
"Hé, moi aussi je suis capable de faire ca". Il y avait très peu de personnes qui avait volé
au début de 1908. En quatre ans, 39 pays avaient des centaines d'avions,
des milliers de pilotes. Les avions ont été inventés par la sélection naturelle.
Maintenant, vous pouvez dire que nos avions actuels sont le fruit d'un procédé bien pensé,
mais il n'y avait rien qui ressemble à un design intelligent avec ces premiers avions.
Il y a probablement eu au moins 30 000 idées différentes qui ont été essayées
et quand l'avion s'écrasait et tuait le pilote, on ne refaisait plus pareil.
Ceux qui volaient et atterrissaient correctement
- parce qu'il n'y avait pas de pilotes formés -
avaient de bonnes qualités de vol à ce moment là, par définition.
Alors, en faisant tout un tas d'essais, des milliers d'essais
pendant cette courte période de 4 ans, on a inventé les bases
des avions qui volent aujourd'hui. Et c'est pour ça qu'ils sont si sûrs,
car on s'est donné les moyens de trouver ce qui était bon.
Ca ne s'est pas passé comme ça pour les vols spatiaux.
On a essayé deux concepts seulement, deux par les Américains et un par les Russes.
Eh bien, qui a-t-on fait rêvé durant cette période?
L'hebdomadaire Aviation Week m'a demandé de faire une liste de ceux que je pensaient
être les précurseurs des 100 premières années de l'aviation.
J'ai écrit la liste et je me suis rendu compte que chacun d'entre eux
était un enfant lors de ce magnifique âge d'or de l'aviation.
Eh bien, que s'est-il passé lorsque j'étais enfant ? Pas mal de choses aussi.
L'ère des avions à réaction commençait, celle des missiles aussi. Von Braun était en train
de montrer comment aller sur Mars - et c'était avant Spoutnik.
Et c'était à une époque où la planète Mars était terriblement plus intéressante
qu'elle ne l'est maintenant. On pensait qu'il y aurait des animaux,
on savait qu'il y avait des plantes, les couleurs changent, pas vrai ?
Mais, vous savez, la NASA a tout foutu en l'air en envoyant ces robots
et ils n'ont atterri que dans les déserts.
(Rires)
Si on regarde à ce que s'est passé, cette petite ligne noire est la vitesse la plus élevée à laquelle un homme ait jamais volé,
et la ligne rouge est celle du maximum pour les chasseurs militaires,
et la ligne bleue, celle des transports commerciaux.
Vous voyez ici, il y a un grand saut. Quand j'étais petit,
et je pense que c'est lié au fait de me donner le courage
d'explorer et de tenter des choses nouvelles que les autres n'avaient pas le courage d'essayer.
Eh bien, qu'est ce que je faisais quand j'étais petit ?
Je ne m'occupais pas de vieilles voitures, des filles ou de booms.
Et aussi, on avait pas de drogues en ce temps-là. Mais je faisais des avions pour des compétitions de modélisme.
J'ai passé environ sept ans pendant la guerre du Vietnam
à tester des avions d'essais pour l'Air Force
Et ensuite, je m'en suis allé et je me suis beaucoup amusé en construisant des avions
que les gens peuvent construire dans leur garage.
Et plus de 3000 de ces avions volent. Evidemment, l'un d'entre eux,
Voyager, fait le tour du monde. En 1982, j'ai fondé une autre entreprise
qui est ma société actuelle.
Et on a développé plus d'un nouveau type d'avion par an depuis 1982.
Et il y en a beaucoup que je ne peux en fait pas vous montrer sur ce tableau.
L'avion le plus impressionant de tous les temps, à mon avis, a été conçu
seulement une douzaine d'année après que le premier réacteur d'avion est devenu opérationnel.
Il est resté en service jusqu'au moment où il était trop rouillé pour voler.
On a retiré du service en 1998 quelque chose qui avait été développé en 1956. Quoi ?
Le vaisseau spatial le plus impressionant de tous les temps, à mon avis,
était l'alunisseur Grumman Lunar Lander. Vous savez, atterrir sur la Lune,
décoller de la lune, sans besoin du personnel de maintenance,
c'est plutôt cool.
On a perdu cette capacité. On l'a abandonnée en 1972.
Cet engin a été conçu seulement trois ans après que Gagarine aille dans l'espace pour la première fois en 1961.
Trois ans ... Et on ne sait plus faire ça maintenant.
C'est insensé. Parlons brièvement des cycles d'innovation, des choses qui grandissent,
connaissent une activité importante et ensuite s'effacent et sont remplacées par autre chose.
Ces cycles arrivent tous 25 ans,
40 ans avec des chevauchements. On peut voir ça
dans tous les types de technologies.
Au fait, ici : "Vitesse maximum atteinte"
est le titre de ces cycles d'innovation. Mais il n'y en a aucune ici.
Ces deux nouveaux avions vont a la même vitesse qu'un DC8 qui lui a été fabriqué en 1958.
Voila le point clef, et c'est qu'il n'y a pas de cycles d'innovations
si le gouvernement développe et utilise quelque chose.
Vous savez, un bon exemple est, bien sûr, Darpanet.
Les ordinateurs ont été utilisés d'abord pour l'artillerie, ensuite pour les impôts.
Mais quand on s'y est mis, on voit le niveau d'activité
et tous les bénéfices qui en découlent. Le secteur privé doit s'en charger.
Gardez ça l'esprit.
J'ai cherché des cycles d'innovations dans le spatial et je n'en ai pas trouvés.
La toute première année, quand Gagarine est allé dans l'espace
et quelques semaines plus tard, Alan Shepard, il y a eu cinq
vols habités dans le monde ; la toute première année.
En 2003, tous ceux que les Etats-Unis ont envoyés dans l'espace ont été tués.
Il y a seulement eu trois ou quatre vols en 2003.
En 2004, il a seulement eu deux vols : deux vols russes sur Soyouz
vers la Station Spatiale Internationale. Et j'ai dû en faire trois depuis le désert de Mojave
avec mon petit groupe de quelques dizaines de personnes
pour arriver à un total de cinq :
ce qui était le même nombre qu'en 1961.
Il n'y a pas de croissance, pas d'activité, rien du tout.
Voici une photo prise depuis SpaceShipOne.
C'est une photo prise depuis l'orbite.
Notre but, c'est de faire en sorte que vous puissiez avoir cette vue et vraiment en profiter.
Maintenant, on sait comment faire pour les vols suborbitaux, de manière sûre,
au moins aussi sûre que les premières compagnies d'aviation, ça c'est faisable.
Et je pense que je veux aborder pourquoi nous avons eu le courage
de sortir des sentiers battus et d'essayer même en étant une petite entreprise.
Bien, tout d'abord, quelle est la prochaine étape ?
La première industrie sera avec de gros volumes et beaucoup d'acteurs.
Il y a eu une annonce de plus, rien que le semaine dernière.
Et ça sera suborbital. La raison pour laquelle ça doit être suborbital,
c'est qu'il n'y a pas encore de solution assez sûre
pour faire voler le grand public en orbite. Les gouvernements l'ont fait,
trois gouvernements l'ont fait pendant ces 45 dernières années
et 4% des gens qui ont quitté l'atmosphère en sont morts.
Vous ne pouvez pas faire marcher un business avec ce genre de statistiques.
Ce sera en volumes très importants : nous pensons que 100 000 personnes voleront d'ici à 2020.
Je ne peux pas vous dire quand cela commencera,
parce que je ne veux pas que mes compétiteurs connaissent mon agenda.
Mais je pense qu'une fois que ça démarrera, on trouvera des solutions.
Et très vite, vous verrez des complexes hôteliers en orbite.
Et un truc vraiment simple à faire, c'est un passage autour de la Lune
où on peut avoir cette vue sensationelle. Ça sera vraiment sensationnel.
Parce que la Lune n'a pas d'atmosphère
on peut faire une orbite elliptique et éviter la surface à 3 mètres près si vous voulez.
Oh, ça va être le pied.
(Rires)
Bon, mes critiques disent : "Hé, Rutan est juste en train de dépenser
plein d'argent de ces milliardaires pour se balader dans l'espace.
Ca rime à quoi ? C'est pas un système de transport, c'est juste pour s'amuser."
Et avant ça m'ennuyait ces commentaires, mais après j'ai réfléchi.
attendez une minute. J'ai acheté mon premier ordinateur Apple en 1978.
et je l'ai acheté parce que je pouvais dire : "J'ai un ordinateur chez moi et pas vous."
"Et ça sert à quoi ? Venez voir il y a Frogger." Bon.
(Rires)
Pas les ordinateurs des banques ou de Lockheed
mais les ordinateurs personnels, c'était pour s'amuser.
Et pendant toute une décennie, c'était pour s'amuser, on ne savait même pas à quoi ça pourrait servir.
Mais ce qui s'est passé, le fait qu'il y a eu cette industrie importante,
des gros développements, grandes améliorations et possibilités et ainsi de suite,
et ils étaient installés dans assez de foyers, nous étions mûrs pour une nouvelle invention.
Et l'inventeur est dans la salle.
Al Gore a inventé l'internet et, grâce à ça,
ce qui était utilisé pendant toute une année, pardon,
pendant toute une décennie pour s'amuser - a tout transformé, notre commerce, notre recherche,
nos communications et si on laisse les gens de chez Google
réfléchir quelques week-ends de plus, on va ajouter une douzaine de choses à la liste.
Et il ne faudra pas longtemps avant que vous ne puissiez convaincre des gosses
qu'on n'a pas toujours eu des ordinateurs dans nos maisons.
Donc s'amuser est un argument défendable.
OK, je veux vous montrer d'image trop chargée,
mais dedans on y retrouve ma prédiction de ce qui va se passer.
Et ca m'amène aussi à un autre point, juste ici.
Il y a un groupe de personnes qui se sont manifestées
et vous ne les connaissez pas tous, mais ceux qui se sont manifestés
ont été inspirés quand ils étaient enfants, entre 3 et 15 ans,
par nous qui allions en orbite et sur la Lune, juste ici,
juste dans cette période de temps.
Paul Allen, Elan Musk, Richard Branson, Jeff Bezos, la famille Ansari,
qui finance maintenant les activités suborbitales russes,
Bob Bigelow, une station spatiale privée, et Carmack.
Ces gens prennent de l'argent et le mettent dans un secteur intéressant
et, à mon avis, c'est bien mieux que de le mettre pour avoir
de meilleurs téléphones portables ou autres. Mais ils le mettent dans dans secteurs
qui vont nous mener vers ce genre de nouvelles possibilités
et qui nous mèneront vers la prochaine grande étape
et cela nous permettra d'explorer. Et je pense que finalement
ça nous permettra de coloniser et d'éviter l'extinction de la race humaine.
Ils ont été inspirés par des progrès énormes. Mais regardons à ce qui s'est passé après.
Il avait quelques exemples ici.
Le plus performant des chasseurs militaires
était le SR71. Il a duré tout un cycle et est devenu trop rouillé pour voler.
Il a été retiré du service. Le Concorde a doublé la vitesse du transport aérien.
Il a duré tout un cycle de vie sans concurrence puis
été retiré du service. Et on est toujours coincé ici
avec le même genre de performances pour les chasseurs militaires
et les vols commerciaux que ce qu'on avait à la fin des années 50.
Mais quelque chose existe pour faire rêver nos enfants aujourd'hui.
Et je parle de ceux qui ont un bébé maintenant,
ou un enfant de 10 ans.
Ce qu'il y a, c'est que quelque chose de très intéressant va se passer ici.
Assez rapidement, il vous sera possible d'acheter un ticket
et de voler plus haut et plus rapidement que les meilleurs
chasseurs militaires en activité. Ça n'a jamais été le cas avant.
Le fait qu'ils soient coincés là avec ce genre de performances
était, bien vous savez, vous gagnez la guerre en 12 minutes,
pourquoi avez-vous besoin de quelque chose de meilleur ?
Mais je pense que, quand vous ici commencerez à acheter des tickets et à voler
sur des vols suborbitaux vers l'espace, très bientôt -- attendez une minute,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ici, on aura des chasseurs militaires
avec des capacités suborbitales et ça très bientôt, à mon avis.
Mais ce qui est intéressant ici, c'est que des gens vont y arriver en premier avec des fonds privés.
J'attends vraiment avec impatience la prochaine course capitaliste vers l'espace.
Vous vous souvenez que la course à l'espace dans les années 60 était pour le prestige national
parce que nous avons perdu les deux premières étapes importantes.
Nous ne les avons pas perdues techniquememt. Le fait est que nous avions le matériel
pour envoyer quelque chose en orbite quand on a laissé Von Braun le faire voler.
On peut soutenir que ce n'était pas un défaite technique.
Spoutnik n'était pas un défaite technique mais une perte de prestige.
Le monde a vu les Etats-Unis n'étant pas les leaders technologiques
et c'était quelque chose de très fort.
Et après on a fait voler Alan Shepard, quelques semaines après Gagarine,
pas des mois, ni des années ou quoi que ce soit. Ainsi on en avait la capacité.
Mais les Etats-Unis ont perdu. On a perdu. Et à cause de cela, on a fait un grand bond en avant pour récupérer.
Et à nouveau, ce qui est intéressant ici, c'est que nous avons perdu
face aux Russes sur les quelques premières étapes.
On ne peut pas acheter un ticket pour aller dans l'espace aux Etats-Unis.
On ne peut pas. Mais on peut en acheter un en Russie.
On peut voler sur de l'équipement russe. C'est disponible
parce que le programme spatial russe meurt de faim.
C'est bien pour eux d'avoir 20 millions ici et là pour occuper un des sièges.
C'est commercial, ça peut être défini comme du tourisme spatial. Ils proposent aussi un voyage
pour faire cette boucle autour de la Lune, comme Apollo 8.
100 millions de dollars -- Hé, je peux aller sur la Lune.
Mais vous savez, qui aurait pensé, dans les années 60,
en plein milieu de la course à l'espace,
que la première activité commerciale de style capitaliste,
acheter un billet pour aller sur la Lune, se ferait avec du matériel russe ?
Et auriez-vous pensé, les Russes auraient-ils pensé
que la première fois qu'ils iraient sur la Lune avec leur équipement,
les gars à l'intérieur ne seraient pas Russes ? Peut-être que ce sera un milliardaire
japonais ou américain ? Eh bien, c'est bizarre vous savez, vraiment.
Mais de toute façon, je pense que nous devons les battre à nouveau.
Je pense que ce qu'on fera, c'est qu'on verra une brillante, très brillante,
industrie privée du vol spatial habité. Qu'on soit les premiers ou pas n'a pas vraiment d'importance.
Les Russes ont, en fait, fait voler un avion de transport supersonique avant le Concorde.
Ensuite ils ont fait plusieurs vols de cargo et l'ont retiré du service.
Je pense qu'on peut voir le même genre de parallèle
quand les possibilités commerciales seront disponibles.
Bon, on va parler un petit peu des développements commerciaux pour les vols habités.
Cette petite chose dit qu'ils représenteront cinq fois
ce que la NASA fera en 2020. Je voudrais déjà vous dire
qu'il y a entre 1,5 milliard et 1,7 milliard de dollars
d'investissement dans les vols spatiaux privés qui ne viennent pas du tout gouvernement ;
déjà et dans le monde entier. Si vous lisez ou utilisez Google,
vous pouvez trouver environ la moitié de cette somme, mais le double
a été engagé, pas encore dépensé mais déjà engagé
et prévu pour les prochaines années. Et c'est plutôt beaucoup.
Cependant, je prédis que cette industrie va être très rentable,
elle va sûrement l'être quand on fait voler des gens pour 200 000 dollars
avec quelque chose qui vous coûte un dixième du prix à mettre en oeuvre,
ou moins, ça va être très rentable.
Je prédis aussi que les investissements qui vont être injectés
seront aux alentours de la moitié de ce que les contribuables américains
dépensent pour le programme de vol habité de la NASA.
Et chaque dollar injecté dedans sera utilisé plus efficacement
d'un facteur de 10 ou 15. Et ça veut dire que, avant qu'on s'en rende compte,
le progrès dans les vols spatiaux habités, sans argent du contribuable,
sera à un niveau 5 fois plus important
que le budget actuel de la NASA pour les vols spatiaux habités.
Et cela, parce que c'est nous. C'est le privé.
On ne devrait jamais dépendre du gouvernement pour ce genre de choses.
On l'a fait pendant une longue période. La NACA, avant la NASA,
n'a jamais développé un avion de ligne ou opéré une compagnie aérienne.
Mais la NASA a développé une compagnie de transport spatial, l'a toujours fait,
et opère la seule compagnie de transport spatial. Et nous nous en sommes tenus à l'écart
parce qu'on en avait peur. Mais en juin 2004,
quand j'ai montré ce qu'un petit groupe isolé pouvait vraiment faire,
pouvait démarrer quelque chose, tout a changé après ça.
Bon, merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)